[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
n
what's up guys what's up good to see you
happy Friday welcome to the stream it's
going to be a very fun stream this
stream is going to go down in history
because Sam
Lazarus from roko is joining us and and
we are covering
the the tricky subject of character
retargeting guys we're covering it in
every single program that ever exists in
the whole
world just kidding we're just covering
the main programs we're going to cover
blender we're going to cover c4d we're
going to cover Maya we're going to cover
Unreal Engine um Sam is going to be
guiding myself and yall through the
process of character retargeting for all
these fun 3D challenges that we do
specifically this one uh Eternal Ascent
right it's got you guys you know putting
your custom character on the mocap data
locking up some steps so we're going to
get you guys covered I know a lot of you
guys have questions so here's what we're
going to do here's how it's going to go
down uh first off what's up everybody
Welcome to the stream good to see you
thanks for joining us on this
Friday we're going to start um in
blender cuz I feel like most of you guys
use blender we're going to Sam's going
to show you the all the tools and tips
for retargeting and blender so Deonte
he's also on Deck he's going to chime in
if needed for anything um we're going to
get through the process in blender we'll
show you that and then if you guys have
Q&A for blender we're going to do that
Q&A for blender right then we're going
to move on we're going to touch Cinema
we're going to get in there Sam's going
to show you the character retargeting
set up in Cinema 4D same deal after the
process we'll open up to Q&A for Cinema
same for Maya and then same for unreal
which we'll spend most of our time in
unreal um you know and then after that
we'll just hang out we'll do some more
q& for you guys um let's see let's
see so uh announcement wise before we
hop over to Sam uh actually some really
cool news for you guys so kit bash 3D is
joining us for this challenge they're
stepping up for bonus prizes for y'all
freaking insane so the top five you guys
are all getting 3 months of cargo Pro
those top five winners right if you guys
don't know about cargo it's their new
like asset Library you can go through
and pick individual assets whole kits
whatever you know it's in down to the
individual asset on cargo Pro it's
amazing I've been using it in my art
we'll get there later in the Stream and
then the top 100 each of you guys get
one kit of your choice of five kits
right so um very cool super awesome for
the people at kit bash there's a link
down below the sponsor link if you look
at I believe it's the third or fourth
link under sponsors kit bat 3D hot head
on over and I got you guys 20% off for
cargo Pro using that link click that
link Down Below guys get to it um so
thank you to the good people at Kip bash
3D y'all are awesome thanks for thanks
for joining us on this
challenge um with with that I think uh
there's only one other thing roko um not
roko let's see Sam he gave us a very
important file and it is a mocap
skeleton file a mixo skeleton file that
you can find on the Discord download
that it's going to make retargeting
easier we're going to get into it um but
I believe that's the last update SL
announcement and there's a bunch of
resource links below for the you for you
guys to follow for retargeting
everything retargeting we got it uh
split up into blender c4d unreal so
without further Ado guys let's get to
our guest let's hop on
over
Sam dude yes yes thank you thank you
thank
you thank
you dude absolutely absolutely man I had
to I had to pull out the beanie
um dude honestly like got a few of those
you know Beanie Baby's baby
um yeah dude and thank you for like I
remember um you know when we were
getting the project files uhoh okay so
they can't hear
Sam oh it's fixed
all right all right we're back what's up
Sam how you doing dude okay the
important thing I said is my biker gang
is going to be called the Beanie Babies
that was the most important information
that you just missed I think yeah and
thank you Clint for having me that too
yeah boom that was perfect that was
perfect um guys I want to hear the
thumbs UPS I want to see the thumbs UPS
in chat when we can hear Sam S Monte
says we're fixed but just want to make
sure I'm muted
too sooda we good oh just me baby now
okay Welcome to My Stream today we're
talking I don't know about bees I guess
s Monte where are
you soda's
gone h no I'm here I'm here I'm just
this is our this is our all right we're
set I'm seeing thumbs got it this means
that nothing else is go wrong now we've
got there's
always it's always hopefully those the
announcements you guys hear me on the
announcements ooh we're good on the
announcements can y'all confirm that you
could hear me on the
announcements see look every time that's
why I get so nervous during these
streams there's always one thing there's
always one thing okay okay heard heard
thank you guys thank
you all right so beanie babies is the
biker gang um what's up Sam good to see
you we're talking character retargeting
today um all
programs um let's see what else are we
getting into dude so yes I was going to
say that when I was um so cypo put
together the Unreal Engine file for this
challenge I took that file and I was
like hey Sam is this set up okay and you
were like
[Music]
bro let me help you
yeah and I was like thank God and you
walked me through like the u4 u5
mannequin setup and I'm like dude this
is so over my head would you just be
down to come on stream and walk people
through and you're like absolutely I
wasn't going to ask you but yes thank
you for being here this this stream will
go down in history because everyone is
going to be referencing this for all
time on all these challenges cuz it's
such a confusing subject why is it so
confusing Sam yes I I well yeah and
again and I thank you for having me as I
as I might have been muted but like I am
a huge fan I don't complete enough
weekly challenges or you know but I'm
like this is so awesome for me to be
here and yeah I am also excited to be
here because um you
know Roco like we've made it very easy
to make motion capture but that is such
a mo mocap is tough it's something that
most people don't have experience with
usually in the Indie world people maybe
have used mixo um to do it it's very
automatic but when it comes to like
getting your map animation onto a
character for lots of reasons one being
it's always been so expensive and Out Of
Reach that's like slowly changed with
roko but all the other companies um but
that means that a lot of generalists
haven't touched that world before and
it's and it's a doozy of a world it's
it's a lot of rotation key frame it's
just it's a tough thing and it can be
really confusing
and so I'm happy to be here to like
spread the gospel of it's it's totally
manageable it's possible there are great
resources online whether they're were
coco or others like it's doable and it's
really cool when you kind of
unlock having access to that stuff even
if it's like I've got your old moving
meditations map like if you want to use
that you know there's so many cool
things you can do with map and I'm happy
to like try to get people a little bit
further to understanding how to do it
because it is scary and yeah as you know
you know yeah 100% And like it it's
something that I am going to have a lot
of questions like honestly this stream
is selfishly for me CU I so
much no and it's awesome it's going to
be good to have you asking questions as
we go as someone who is very focused on
an end result right like that's the
thing is you'll have hopefully really
great questions about
like not the Theory but the practice
like how do I actually what are you
doing there what tab is that like stop
what is that let talk about that so
let's do it all right so um like we
talked about do we want to hop into
blender first and talk about I want to
do my quick Spiel firstview let's do the
overview tell about the overview yeah
yeah and I wish I had like a slide or
something but I don't okay I think the
so we're going to get into all these
programs today I think Clint has the
chat for questions hope there'll be
questions that we'll be able to answer
the first thing that I always say in my
Spiel though is I am um I'm a
generalist um there are many ways to do
these things that we're going to be
doing so what we're going to be going
over today are what I think are some of
the best ways to do it they're the ways
that I do it personally but that does
not mean they're the only way to do it
and it also doesn't mean that what we're
going to cover is going to cover any
situation as everyone here knows CG
every project is different every model
is different so so this is won't
necessarily be a cure all for all your
problems I hope it it will be very
helpful but there are many ways to do
things that's that's a and b like I'm
not a main blender user like don't come
at me for not using blender hot keys I'm
sorry like there will be things that I
am only partially versed in as as we get
into all this um so that's my cover my
ass the disclaimer the terms and
condition at the top the disclaimer
which I think is is just true it's CG is
so varied um okay but the other thing
that I want to go through is just the
overview of motion capture that we're
going to be talking about because even
though we're going to be in different
programs today really Map works in a in
a kind of a the same way no matter the
program in the broad strokes and so I
just want to talk about those like super
briefly and the first step for motion
capture is always definition so you've
got your motion capture animation you've
got your Rigg character and these
programs are dumb they don't know
inherently that the left arm bone on
your map is the left arm bone and they
don't know that the left arm bone on
your character is the left arm bone so
the first step when you're doing map
retargeting which is what we're going to
be doing today which is the process of
taking motion capture putting it on a
character is something we call
definition bone definition bone Maps
it's where we go in and we tell the
program hey this is the left arm of my
map this is the left arm on my character
and we do that so that in the next step
which is the retargeting it knows which
is just copying animation it's just
copying key frame animation from one
bone to another like that's all you know
map is that's all retargeting is it's
yeah it's very simple it's very dumb
it's it's just copying key frames um but
you need to tell the programs which
where the key frame should go right
that's the definition stage defin Define
then we copy our map to our character
retargeting and then we have the editing
stage and in with a lot of motion
capture you usually sometimes you don't
need to do any editing the file that
Clint has created is actually really
clean already it looks really good but
you might get things where for example
in the characters I've been working with
the arms will be clipping through the
legs right things like that yeah like
you know and that goes all the way up to
getting very detailed I want my
character to be holding a shield or to
be waving a flag right that's all going
to be done in the editing stage and the
key with editing is you want to do it
non-destructively and there are tools in
all the programs we're going to talk
about today where there's a layering
animation system which means we've got
our base animation at the bottom but we
can throw a layer on top of that and do
additive animation on top of that cuz we
don't want to delete the animation
that's already there mhm right yeah so
that's a key part of this as well and
those are kind of the stages of motion
capture so that's my Spiel and hopefully
that made sense and so hit the three in
what are the three steps definition you
define then retargeting yeah and then
editing those are like really at any
level of map your Marvel Indie hobby
it's all the same there's there's those
are the steps that every everyone goes
through and and uh and they're so
they're broadly the same in every
program right it's not like the only
program that's a little different as
iclone because you don't have to do
definition really because you can just
drag them in we're not going to talk
about iclone today but broadly you
always follow and we'll you'll see as we
go I'm gonna Point these out as we go
through these programs each stage um
yeah so I think that's valuable to know
I I think great that gets everybody kind
of on the same page like where we're at
no one's going to be so you're defining
when you say the definition meaning
you're making sure that the skeleton the
map skeleton is talking with the
character with the rig they they they
speak the same language essentially
right yeah you're basically and again
it's it's it's a dumb process right
we're just copying key frames from one
joint to another but the program just
has no idea inherently where that data
should go so you need to tell it this is
the left arm map this is the left arm
this is the left forearm moap this and a
lot of this is automated we're going to
be using mixo characters a lot of these
plugins and processes it's like you
select mixo and it like autog generates
you know but if it doesn't it's
important to know that that's a key part
of the process right and and it can be
frustrating because it's like you're
going through the skeleton and like left
arm it's annoying to click sometimes but
it's not that hard again it's like let's
hop into it let's do it let's see what
we got let's get into it um so blend
right you got blender open I got blender
open let's let's do it here we
go again um apologies yeah we're on me
and I'm using uh I'm using not industry
hotkeys in blender so some of these
things might be different from the way
that blender native users are used to
doing things Soo like call me out and if
there are questions I'm happy to answer
them again to the best of my ability but
we're going to start really simple here
so I've got a blank project but but if
you're using the template project you
can you you know I assume you'll be
doing it in the template project um or
something but we're just going to be in
a blank project here because it's just
cleaner um the plugins I'm going to call
out today and and I think there are
links to these in the in the description
below but yeah we're going to be using
the rcoo plugin it's a free plugin for
the retargeting and the and the
definition stages really good easy to
use plugin it's free you need a roko ID
you don't have to use Roco there are
other ones for example the auto rig Pro
plugin which we're going to be using as
well because it has a really good ik
control rig setup um and then also
there's no animation in my scene so you
can't see it but there is a great
animation layers plugin on the blender
Marketplace a lot of you probably
already have it for one reason or
another it's called animation layers
there should be a link to it that's
going to for editing that's going to be
for creating layers and there's also a
native tool and blender that you can use
for that but this one is better so so
we're going to be using that the other
thing that actually I want to point out
before we get started is we are going to
be if there are things that don't come
up today and you want to I have put
together a bunch of tutorials on the
roko YouTube channel go to the roko
YouTube channel this playlist ultimate
retargeting workflows this
has guides oh sorry um for
every uh for every software and like
amazing this will explain things so go
here if you miss something or if it
doesn't clear and that's linked below
correct yeah it should be yeah okay
sweet okay enough talk talkie talkie so
let's the first thing I'm going to do
and and I'm just going to go through
this and you ask questions Clint but uh
we're just going to do it what I've got
here
is a mixo character we're going to be
using a miimo character CU it's a good
Baseline I think a lot of you will be
using mixim characters this will also
work with custom characters but for our
purposes we're going to be using a mixo
character whenever I pull in an fbx and
blender I like to check automatic bone
orientation under Armature makes things
look nice so I'm going to check that and
import and look you know we're starting
off we just got a mixim mo character
boom it's in a t pose that is very
important we want it to be in a t pose
and that's because when we go and we
pull in our motion capture and this is
the file that Clint just added to the
Discord right yeah it's on the Discord
in the announcements under um Eternal
ascent and then I also added it to like
the whole project file if you click
Download Project files it'll be in there
too um and and last thing here A mixim
Pose just to just want to um clarify
when you're on miimo you can choose the
character and you can choose the
animation and the animation you want uh
if you type in to pose you know oh
password hold on now are you good we're
on you yeah no it's fine it doesn't
emails and passwords no you can see my
email whatever uh you know don't spam me
it just never loads but yeah you you you
upload your character then it even if
you uploaded it in a t pose you want to
go to
animations type in t pose and select it
yep yeah so you do want to to do that
yeah and this is like a custom character
that you uploaded to mixo right this is
the custom character that I uploaded the
funny thing about mixo which is good
information is that some of the
characters that are just here especially
the really old one the Legacy ones they
actually have different skeletons than
and what the auto riger will give you if
you upload a character to mixo that's
the best way to know that all this will
work the right way some of these old
characters have like slightly different
skeletons for whatever reason but yeah
we're going to be using this is a
character I uploaded use the Auto riger
Select T pose download boom and that
brings us to here boom boom and it is O
look it has a texture okay but it's in a
toos right that is important so and the
reason it's important is because when we
bring in our map again check automatic
bone
orientation our map is also in a t POS
and that's because when we do our
remember we're just copying key frames
right and and what that means is that
you need the initial orientation of all
those bones to be the same right if
we're copying map key
frames right like for the this this arm
right the right arm it's like down you
know the rotation key frames tell it
like go down to the side on the whatever
the Y AIS right if our character has a
completely different orientation it's
all going to be relative to the initial
orientation right so so basically you
want your character and your mamp to be
in the same pose as close as possible
when you do your retargeting because
we're just copying key frames and if
they're in different poses they're going
to be offset by how different they were
when you copy those key frames over does
that make sense it's always hard to
explain 100% yeah like let me let's see
show a good
example of of like an A Pose yeah let's
see I know I have a video here of when I
did the poor version of this and I
retargeted it in the wrong way so like
this let's see can this Loop does this
Loop will this Loop and the hands are
like in the body like
this where it's
like
yeah you know it's like that was not um
T to T pose that was some weird pose to
some exactly yeah it was janky so the
animation's on there the animation's on
there but it's just not in the right
position because it was offset by how
different the character in the map
starting poses were um the other thing
to mention is this file that I that that
you guys have because we want frame zero
to be a t pose it goes up to 120 frames
so if I shift this back by one frame in
the timeline everything back by one yeah
so you'll you'll have to do that right
to get it to fit into that 120 frames
for this project it's just something to
know that frame zero is a toost that
means that for frame zero to be the
first frame of Animation you're going to
have to move it back but it needs to be
a t pose yeah exactly anyway let's get
to the actual retargeting so we've got
our map let's make sure our project is
yep we're in 24 looks good we hit
play we got the the map right all this
is what we need this is Clint moap so to
retarget this onto our character I'm
going to open up the Roco plugin links
below links links below for install and
everything we're going going to go to
the retargeting section here under
Source I'm going to put in we can check
it to be sure but it's Armature o1 their
name the same thing which is a little
confusing but it's Armature 01 source of
our animation Target where is the
animation going it's going to our
character and you can see then we get
this build bone list and because this is
these are mixim characters it all fills
out automatically so how nice is that
actually it doesn't look the pinky isn't
there
so that might be something I'm not going
to fill it in now but if there are
missing Fields here you would go
[Music]
in oh it looks like there is no pinky on
maybe there is not a pinky on my charact
oh it's not rigged it looks like this
hand didn't have a pinky bone anyway
point being if any of these fields are
blank or even if they're all blank you
just have to go in and you're matching
these up right this is that definition
phase when we tell blender hey look hips
of my map hips of my character spine of
my map spine of my character right and
so you go through and you define
everything and this should be automatic
if you're using mixo character if you're
using customer character you might have
to fill it out you can always hit save
so you only have to do it one time but
pretty easy right should be fairly
automatic and we hit retarget
animation so they don't need to be on
the same level oh wow okay so in cinema
it will like throw it off if they're not
exactly paired in the same spot I guess
is the best way I can describe that
we'll get there we'll get there but
we'll get there yeah yeah no but it it
should be as long as you're in a te pose
um it should be pretty easy and look and
and this process unlike Cinema um this
process what we've done is we've
actually
copied these key frames over so now at
this point look I can
just delete delete my moap I got my um
you know got the so then what do you do
about the clipping hands how do you move
that and like okay so yeah so the
clipping hand so the
um the the the way that we can do it
very simply and there's two ways to do
moap editing there's FK and then there's
ik ik is inverse kinematic FK is forward
kinematic um what you want ideally is to
have an ik control rig and we're going
to be talking about that bit you mean
forward my hand stays and everything
else goes exactly like the hand stays
put and then FK is like like this from
the shoulder rotating from the
shoulder yeah it's always difficult to
explain these things as well but
basically what it means is the way that
you can think about FK and ik and for a
lot of you this is something you'll know
let's say I'm trying to position my arm
in a good way let's say like this FK
basically just means you're going down
the chain you're moving forward through
the end bone yeah you're moving forward
right you're moving forward through the
chain so if I want to move the position
of my wrist I can't I have to move my
upper arm then I have to move my this
arm then I move my wrist right FK or ik
inverse kinematic yeah means going
backwards and what's really cool about
that is say if I want to move the
position of this wrist I can move the
wrist and the rest of the bones will
just
follow where that wrist is going so
ik moap editing is kind of the Holy
Grail of map editing it makes it a lot
easier to do the editing generally
because it means you're just dealing
with those end bones you're not having
to go through a whole chain to move the
wrist and it's often times the wrist or
the foot that we're looking at editing
right those are the things that usually
have clipping
issues whatever it may be um so the way
that we can um go and do some FK editing
on like the hands is first the shoulders
on the hands yeah let's just try and fix
this clipping we you can see that we
have clipping here right like look at
this yeah it's going in this one is a
little bit worse right um so what we can
do is I'm going to use this
animation uh layer add-on again there is
a native if you go to the um where is it
it's called nonlinear animation in
blender I'm not going to go through this
workflow it's in my tutorial on our
YouTube channel if you want to see the
native tools this plugin it's paid but
it's so great for so many things in
blender it's kind of I think worth it
for you to check out if you don't do map
all the time so we're going to use this
called animation layers it's on the
blender Marketplace turn it on and you
can see I've got look at all the key
frames I've got down here on my
character right if I hit plus with my
Armature
selected key frames are gone now does
that mean the moap is gone no no no mo
Cap's still there but what you can see
now sorry my Cadence no no yeah my sham
wow um Cadence but what this this is
really amazing actually because again if
we go to this base layer think about if
you're trying to adjust the movement of
the of an arm that's already key framed
at every key at every frame you'd have
to go every frame and adjust it it would
be so frustrating yeah where as opposed
to if we go to pose mode and again this
is where my uh my blender noobishness
shows and the way that I'm manipulating
this but now there's no key frames on
this because we're in this layer this
anim anim layer which you'll notice is
above my base layer and what we can
do add a key
frame we have not lost our animation the
arm is still moving but it's
persistently fixed it's it's going to
persist and of course we can edit this
right we could okay let's have it move
not that way uh back
down key frame now replay do it again do
it again how did you do that again you
selected let me do it on the head let me
do it on the head better okay and you
can see when I select the head empty
timeline down here it's kind of hidden
behind Clint's video but it's it's an
empty timeline right let's say on my
eternal Ascent I want the character to
look up by the end of the animation
right
well I'm just gonna rotate down the head
I'm hitting s to add a key frame I think
it's sto what is it maybe I'm sure it's
different on non-industry
standard key frame whatever insert key
frame right I'm adding a key frame to
the Head yeah there's a lot of different
ways to do that and then I think it's I
if I'm not it might be I yeah that
sounds right and I'm going to drag it so
you can see it here's my the key frame I
added right you can see the is pointed
down the entire time by the end I want
it to look up to the Future
Hope frame look at that yes dude so
simple and so simple and you can use
this principle to do all the rest of
your animation editing as needed now
what we can also do really quickly or I
don't how are we doing on time on
blender should we move or I I mean we're
we're moving at a good Pace we're going
to hit Q&A and blender in a second guys
so get your questions ready um get ready
to hit me with at pisher when I say not
yet not yet we're going to get there in
a sec um let me set this up one more
time and I want to show another really
cool thing um so this is going to use
the uh Auto rig Pro plugin and I'm just
right now I'm going through the exact
same steps we went through previously
but instead of using the Roco definition
you're using no no no we're going to
we're going to do that too I'm going to
use the roko uh retargeting same same
exact steps I'm just I'm just getting a
clean project here we
go moap done delete my
moap but this time what we're going to
do is we're going to add a quick rig
from Auto rig Pro on top of this so Auto
rig Pro another paid plugin an amazing
plugin I'm not the only one to this is
not a niche this is probably one of the
top plugins on the blender Marketplace
very well established it also means
there's lots of tutorial tutal out there
from many people about how to use it
Beyond Myself which is always good
because I'm not a blender user generally
but basically there's a quick rig add-on
to Auto rig Pro you can see down here
quick rig right and what we can do here
is if I go to import there's a miimo
preset now if there isn't if you have a
custom character the thing I love about
this plugin is it's it's one of the
easier plugins to make
a custom ik control rig um the way you
do it I'm going to load in the mixim one
because we have a mixim character and
but you can see what it does is it gives
you okay spine head leg right if if you
if you aren't using a mixo character
it's still very easy to just it'll give
you these categories spine leg head all
these and you just need to go and like
fill them out with your character
skeleton which is very easy relative to
some of the other systems so in this
case it did it automatically for us but
it the thing that's nice about this this
plugin is that again it's super hard to
create custom ik control rigs normally
this plugin makes it really easy um so
big UPS to this plugin when I hit quick
rig look at this I want to under
animation bake animation arms I want to
do ik
not FK legs it gives me an option I want
ik for the legs too
okay I I click okay and look it has
automatically
added an ik control rig so when we were
talking earlier about the difference
between ik and FK this is ik look I can
grab the wrist and the rest of the arm
just moves ik inverse inverse it's going
from the wrist in and then exactly going
back
that's going up the chain yeah right
yeah depending on your but the important
the important thing is you can grab the
end bone and move it which is so great
and look I've baked oh he's got a
balloon super freaking cool I don't know
why it I don't know why it twisted
this oh it's the whole the whole oh no
it twisted the arm both I'm not going to
worry about that right now but in theory
it should just be um easy to fix that
okay it
did some arm twisting or something but
let's say we even oh yeah and it and it
and it's persistent look because there's
no key
frames
uh on this yet interesting I didn't
think I'd be able to twist it anyway
point being you can use the same thing
that we just did um to create an
animation layer right and then
add if we wanted to this
time
at a key frame and like oh it's so much
easier to I want it to go up
and
whatever uh like scratch his
head or something right
yeah and then we can like make maybe we
have to make some adjustments I'm not
going to spend a ton of time fine-tuning
this but hopefully you can see yeah they
get the point how much for sure yeah
easier it is to do corrections when
you've got an ik system and for a lot of
people I imagine this is really going to
come in handy when changing the terrain
for their stairs right so this just
makes it really easy so yeah if you guys
need to do like fine adjustments to make
sure the foot is stuck onto whatever you
know thing onto that step perfectly then
that's awesome you changed the the stair
cuz you've got a custom environment
obviously and this will this this will
make it really simple and this is all
it's I always say it's
easy that's of course a relative term I
think um you know it's it's complicated
obviously but
also it's it's really it is Achieve like
this is super doable I think and it's
really these are difficult Concepts when
you when you start but they soon become
rote and it soon becomes very easy and
it's so much easier now than it was a
year ago two years ago you know so it's
really great these these methods that we
have now okay so okay I'm I'm going to
I'm going to transition here to Q&A so
if you guys have any blender questions
right now let's just take fiveish
minutes hit me with at pisher in the
chat in the live chat I'm looking at you
guys right now um that way I can see the
comment right it's a little easier if
you do at
pisher um while you guys do
that um those three chapters that you
you have or those three steps Define
retarget edit that's like such a great
way to think about it and I think that
that helps me think about it in a in a
kind of more of a step-by-step process
so that's great um yeah yeah I think
once you understand the the fundamental
what's what's happening and how really
base it is right how dumb it is it is it
is so I get all these questions all the
time for instance about like can I do X
Y and Z with map retargeting can I
retarget it onto like a arm on the
backpack at the end of the day these are
just key framed joints like there's
nothing special about this map animation
it's just key frame joints right so you
can do lots of interesting novel things
um with that animation data but it's
very opaque I think when you first start
looking at retargeting um and I find it
helps knowing that it's just like it's
dumb data right you're it's just key fr
and so you're just you're just copying
them around right uh so we got some good
questions um right now the ones I'm
seeing doubled up are how do you do it
without the animation layers plug
in okay let's do it do I need to move my
head here down here on the bottom left I
know you are searching down there yeah
maybe a little bit um Let me let me see
if I can remember to the Top If if I'm
just
restarting just restarting this cuz
again I'm so bad at blender that like I
can't dude I wouldn't even be able to
orbit you're good okay here you go
you're killing it
um it's it's an interesting thing about
Roco work is that we um we work in all
the different programs so I try I try my
hardest to great so you're you're
recreating the steps the roko plugin is
free right for blender roko plugin free
there's a bu of different plugins to do
it though you do not have to you know I
I like to hey I'm here to you know R's
awesome use Roco but like there's a lot
of different ways there's so many
different circumstances like do what
works for you man um okay first thing
I'm going to do whoa uh yeah
whoa is you can see I got my frame zero
my border my border what happened to my
clothes um my frame I'm just going to
move this back
start so that you know it it does start
on the right thing totally and let's say
I wanted
to go in and just do some FK editing um
the the principle be would be the same
if you have a control rig um but in this
case I'm just going to do it for FK so
I'm going to go to the nonlinear
animation panel uh up here and you can
see what what the nonlinear animation
typically does is it converts all the
animation in your timeline to like these
blocks these easily manipulated blocks
where they're not really separated
out by frame by body part it's like you
got a block of Animation now that we're
working with right like layers in like
Da Vinci like video layers yeah yeah
like yeah it's a layer of Animation
right yeah I mean right it's a layer
it's the nonlinear animation layer so
what we can do is if we click this push
down button you can see I got my my
Baseline animation we've added a layer
on top right so the same thing that we
were we were doing before very simple
we'll go to pose mode the important
thing to know here is that for this
layer we want the blending to be
combined if you make it replace it's
going to replace the animation on that
joint if we do combine the goal is
always to do additive animation we want
to do
nondestructive editing we want to add
something on top of what we already have
we don't want to delete what we already
got right we have that nice walking
motion we just want to change where the
arm is slightly so I want to do
combine and at this
point let's just add a key frame
and move
it sorry let me let me go back and make
it drastic do something really extreme
so you can you can see it add a key
frame hey there it is
now it's
uh over here and and what I always like
to do too is uh and if we get into Maya
there's a great way to do this in Maya
but what you often want to do with with
map editing is you're fixing a specific
point where there's a problem but you
don't really want the rest of the map to
be in that position that you mooved you
know usually it's like you're swinging
let's say you're swinging your arm arm
to uh with a sword right and it's like
at a certain point it cuts through my my
right arm is going through my left arm I
just want to fix that one moment right
move my arm so it isn't intersecting so
what you can do is always grab that
original key frame you
made see if I can do it here I might
have to do I go in and get
it there should be a way to go in and
get the original key frame I'm just too
dumb we may have to go to the timeline
again
yeah so here's that key frame we made
originally right the original position
of the arm untampered I can yeah I can
just copy that back yeah and it goes
back to where it was originally right so
that can be a nice like usually when
you're fixing map clipping problems it
it's like we just we would just do
this let's let's delete this one in the
middle so this is a key frame where
things are ostensibly okay let's
actually move it out a little bit and
let's say it Clips right
here move it out and then like we want
it to go back to where it should be copy
and and add the key frame back that was
a bad example but get it you can kind of
see what I mean yeah you you have your
safe key frame at the beginning that you
can just copy back sweet okay so that's
how you do that um let's see other ones
let's
[Music]
see all right so that that helps the
animation if you guys don't have
animation layers plug in um how much
animation can we change on the character
good question not Lawrence the answer is
just the head just the arms um if you
want them holding something for your
story if you want them looking in a
certain direction for your story yes but
in in general the map data is there the
animation is there to like link all of
the renders together right so so you
don't want to be changing all the steps
and all this and that um let's see T
pose or rest pose that needs to match
what does that
mean yeah this is a great question um so
it means that basically sometimes you
get characters I'm going start a new
project again you can put me back down s
mon
yeah thanks man let me go and grab
another character
yeah this guy's a good example I
think see if it loads in but uh so what
this this question is uh concerning rest
poses versus current poses now this guy
looks like he's in a t- pose right now
but if we go to the edit
mode but don't be
deed yeah normally this guy I set up
correctly but let's go to another
T POS or not t POS I don't know they
look the same to
me yeah you do want it to be in a it's
basically that oh where is a badly set
up guy
um hold
on I think this guy
is O super
cool yeah so here you can kind of see
the difference so
this looks like it's in a t pose right
but often times what will happen
especially if you're using mixo what
will often happen is you load up a
character in an a pose to mixo which is
fine right miimo will love that and that
means a pose just means the arms are
down to the side like this right Yos to
T pose yep a pose is the unreal pose
generally and you rig it up and it looks
great and you download it as a t pose
and you import it into blender and it
looks like it's in a t pose
but when you go to do your moap uh
editing or retargeting you get very
weird results and that's because the
rest pose will still be that a
pose and that is annoying um in cinema
there's a way to fix this that we'll
talk about in blender the way I'm not
going to get into how to fix it on here
cuz I I I'm not a good enough but look
up basically you want to apply as rest
pose in blender there's a bunch of
different ways to do this in blender I
used to use a plugin called the cats
plugin c a TS Capital cats apparently
it's been deprecated for blender 3.5 I
don't think it works in blender 3.5
anymore or above which is
frustrating there are other ways to do
that but but what you need to do
is you need to go and apply the T pose
as the rest pose of your character and
that means when you go into edit mode
there should be your character shouldn't
shift like this right this this means
that the rest pose this is the real pose
of this character which actually is a t-
pose which is ironic normally like this
would jump into the a pose right um and
and what that means is that when you do
your retargeting
it's actually going to be offset as if
it was in an A Pose so it it can be
really frustrating I have in the
tutorials that I have on my YouTube I I
there should be a way to to deal with
that but really there's lots of
tutorials on blender about getting your
character into its rest pose and that's
the key word you want to be searching
for rest pose apply as rest pose blender
sooda I don't even know maybe you have
like an easier answer for this for me
whenever I'm in blender and I there's
like a there's a command that's called
like how do you search and blender is it
tab the right click I think so there's
people in chat three but as far as I
know you can just go to post mode and
then on the top left menu click post
apply post address post or something
like that but maybe it's too simple I
don't know it's it's really that is like
how it should
work oh God I see this is where my
blender like Dum comes in I don't even
know it's fine I think we can I think we
can move on I think there some there's
some options in chat people are giving
some potential fixes in chat take a look
at that you guys are stuck there um but
I think we should move on if there's not
a another question um let's see
characters May glitch on the
stairs
uh see let's see any good questions we
can hit
here
[Music]
um ashin what's the difference between
the blender files V1 versus V4 so
um basically we only made one update to
the blender file um and that is
um sodon just added the T POS in the
mocap data on frame zero as opposed to
negative 1 so you see it on frame zero
and then he deleted some data that just
didn't need to be in there that bloated
the file that's it um but I think just
to be clear there's only two versions
the four is probably because now we have
the version one and the version two for
blender 4.0 and 3.0 that's the last
thing yeah um they were able to I think
I cats did the 3.0 right
um we split it upep yep yeah so for
those of you in 3.0 all right moving on
to cinema um let's do it to it okay how
do you see now now we're into my neck of
the woods but I
still It's Tricky It's Tricky for me
well yeah and the unfortunate thing
about Cinema is that it is and I love
Cinema I am a cinema guy I started in
cinema it's still my my main um although
unreal's coming for it the it's
unfortunately Cinema 40 has
the uh weakest retargeting tools it just
kind of does and and part of that also
is because for blender you have a
blender Marketplace you've got all these
plugins that people have made you've got
all these free you know tools that
people have created Cinema it just the
native tools are not um the easiest
unfortunately and uh it's just you're a
little bit more limited in cinema so I
think that's something good to know
going in it might be more frustrating
work in cinema it just is it's possible
though it's just kind of yeah it's super
possible we're g to go through it it's
it's just more basic you're limited a
little bit let's do it let's dive in
okay so I'm going to go and we're going
to do the exact same thing I'm grabbing
my
miimo
rigged
character uh I'm not going to reassign
takes one thing I always like to do in
cinema is make sure that this
lock override is unchecked in the take
system it can just cause problems I
found in various ways so turn that off
it's just a good idea unless you're
using the take system for some reason um
here I've got my character right mixim
rigged character and let's be organized
create a null alt
G uh
character so there we go we got our
character mixo rigged and Cinema I think
is another another good thing to mention
is Cinema has a bunch of Integrations
with mixo so if you're doing map
retargeting in cinema it's the easiest
if you're using a mixo character and it
there's it everything kind of works
better there's more options
so it's great if you're using a mixo
character it's it's a little bit easier
um so I'm going to create alt G
everything selected I got my map and I
got my character and let's set my
timeline to 12 frames we press play this
again is that map file that that is now
in the Discord right that has the T pose
yep yep T pose at frame zero again so
important to know that frame zero will
be a t pose and in cinema we're going to
use something called the character
definition tag
definition step one step one target step
one exactly uh I'm going to get a
t-shirt made of this yes um um so we'll
start with our character I'm going to
right click you want to right click or
set this character definition tag which
is under rigging tags character
definition I'm going to put that on the
topmost bone in my skeleton chain which
usually is the hips it's almost always
going to be the hips I might be able to
put it on this null but I don't think
that's very clean so put it on the hips
and that's the best way to do it cool we
click that tag you can see I've got open
manager down here click on that and
we've got a character definition list
right we've got torso we've got hips
spine neck we've got all the different
bones for you to fill out now again
because we're using a mixo character
that we download from mixo I can just
hit extract skeleton it does it all for
me look it filled out all this stuff
automatically it's got all my spine
bones it's got my
fingers everything is set up
automatically for me again something
weird about the ring finger in this
model but if the ring finger isn't here
if there's a blank joint section up here
see
ring control click to expand out the
entire tree here of my skeleton I could
just go oh there's only three bones on
my character for whatever so you can
actually in mixim you can choose how the
hands are set up you can choose
individual fingers you can choose like
Mitten or you can choose like you know
whatever I don't know this must be a
mitten yeah um but anyway if if you're
if you have to do this manually the the
way that you do it is you just go find
those bones and like ring finger you
would go and you would
[Music]
grab your ring finger bones these these
aren't this is index but you just drag
them
in now they're in right I'm going to
delete these um but if you need to do it
manually that's how you go through and
you define for each of these things
what's what because it was a mixo
character easy we don't need to do it it
does it automatically when we hit
extract skeleton then I'll hit set
reference pose that locks it in boom
defined for our character yeah it's it's
saying the orientation we want to do our
retargeting is this this pose I have
right here this T pose so boom then
we're going to do the same thing for our
map go to the hips rigging tags
character
definition open manager on the tag right
with the tag selected we get these
options this is a the map that take that
we've provided is a mixim skeleton that
means extract it all works perfectly for
this one the ring fingers will be in
there everything is good right so that's
all good to
go set reference pose now for our
character we're going to click on that
character definition tag and we're going
to click create
solver and as soon as we do that we get
a new little tag up here this is a
character solver tag and Target
character we have our I keep saying
character it can get kind of confusing
but basically our our mixim character is
under Target we want to drag in under
Source the moap right so this tag drag
it into source and now when we hit
play HEK yeah
easy peasy that's great um super great
super easy looks great um so it's a
pretty simple process and you again if
you have a custom character you've got a
character creator character you've got a
Daz character you might have to under
the character definition tag go in and
manually set up those bones it's you can
save a preset so you don't have to do it
multiple times and but once you've told
the program which bones are which this
solver tag will work the same way and it
should just work um so do you want to
show motion tile or motion what is it
called what is it called a motion clip
yeah so let's let's talk about yeah I
think what's important also to note is
that if I click on so here's my
character on the hips there's no key
frames on this hip if we go in on my
moap look these are all the animation
key frames the reason there's no key
frame on my hip is because this moap is
being
transferred it's like referencing it's
yeah this solver is like saying okay
whatever the skeleton with animation is
doing like do that what makes that tough
is if we if I do this retargeting in
here and then I go to my template file
create a new file I paste in well I
don't have any of that animation CU it
was a reference to my motion capture so
what we want to do is is we want to bake
all these key frames we want to bake it
to my character so it's not just saying
calling back to my map right if that
makes sense totally the way that we yeah
the way that we do that and this is also
how you unlock rudimentary editing is
I'm going to go to my characters
skeleton I'm going
to select children select all the bones
in my character skeleton
mhm then I'm going to go to the dope
sheet which I hate it docks it in here
for some reason for me which is super
annoying but this is the dope sheet
window dope sheet shift F3 and with all
my
characters bone selected I'm going to go
to functions fake
objects and we want to uncheck create
copy we don't want to create a copy we
want to bake down all these key frames
and it's going to do it for the length
of my timeline so 0 to 120 it won't do
it for more or less than what's here and
if I hit bake it's baked it down now I
can delete my motion capture I can
delete my
tags and I've still got see all the
these key frames are actually on here
which is which is really great that's
cool so super cool I can now you copy
this to a new project file it's all
going to be animated still sick great
Standalone yeah now the the the last bit
of this the map uh editing bit of this
is we are going to click on my hips
we're going to go to animate add motion
clip and again we want to uncheck remove
included animation we don't want to
remove the animation we want to uncheck
that hit okay and you can see we get
this little tag
here and it's a motion clip tag and we
can hit open andl and here now we've got
this should look like what we just
looked like in blender right all the
broad Strokes of what we're doing in all
these programs are similar right to do
editing to do non-destructive map
editing you want layers right you're
adding layers on top of that base
animation and here we have a nonlinear
animation system again we've we've added
all of our motion capture into this one
block look if I move this thing around
just like you're move yep exactly I can
I will want to because again frame zero
is my T pose I do want to move this by
one frame over right so that it's
actually on the on the right thing but
what we can do now is if we wanted to
make changes to our motion capture
excuse my window browsing I just want
you to be able to see the timeline here
again we've got animation key frames on
all of the frames we go to our motion
clip tag we hit add it's going to add a
new new layer in here click add and look
again all those key frames are gone I'll
move this layer up above our base and
now we can go in and we can start
doing
FK uh changes
so you know I can uh sorry let me how do
I make this
cleaner move this over here I can add a
key frame and let's say what do the head
again actually the head is a really good
one sometimes I find that like it won't
register the first key frame unless you
actually
move the head I don't know why but I
moved the head slightly and added a key
frame now as he's walking up I want him
to look to the heavens add a key frame
we just added that on top right so it's
the same principle that we just looked
at if I want to have him look up and
then look back back down right I can
always control click on this key
frame
uh Hey control hold down control it
creates a copy I can just I could I
guess control C copy it whatever but
look the the head moves
up oh no golly what happened um I will
use this this time to say if you guys
have any questions for Sam in Cinema 4D
for character retargeting hit us there
I'm not going to answer any rules
questions I'm just going to try and keep
it focused to character retargeting in
c4d um I can answer that stuff a little
bit later once we get through to the end
I want to try and get through all these
programs because we still got Maya after
this and then we're going to hit unreal
yeah and then unreal yeah um so yeah you
can see here that it's looking up right
and and what we just went through with
that confusion of the key frames like
that is a a symptom of Cinema 4D and the
way that this system is set up it's a
little bit messy you might run into
problems that are confusing or don't
seem to logically make sense like I
added a key frame why is it not
registering it's part of the
cinema situation right now so it's just
it that is to be kind of expected um so
you might run into issues like that but
again if you go to the Roco YouTube like
I lay this all out in the tutorial it
should linked Below guys all that stuff
linked below there's a whole Cinema
section whole blender section Maya and
unreal section with a bunch of links
from Sam down below so check that out um
I'm looking at chat right now
and um I'm not seeing any c4d
questions um let's cruise it I say we
move on let's hit Maya back but yeah
let's do
it uh I'll save this just in case we
want
to
yeah thank you just in case we want to
come back to this guy okay we're going
to
Maya
um so I'm in Maya 2022 does not matter
Maya has not changed and never will
change in any it does it has bugs from
30 years ago and it still
um it's a good thing or bad thing you
know it's like uh St consistent that's
nice it is extremely consistent Maya is
the best program for retargeting it just
is it has 40 years of being the main
animation system in the whole CG world
it is the best at doing retargeting
there it it creates custom control rigs
really easily it's amazing um is there
like a student version of Maya like is
there a way for people there's a yeah
there is a student version and they have
an indie license now too that's a 300
bucks a year or something like that
which is much better than the 1500 Buck
the year used to be jeez um but there a
student is free they can they can do all
this stuff on student I think it's I
think it's for you need to have an email
address from your institution though
okay all right all right a little tricky
maybe but hey we're here for the people
that have Maya here we are yeah yeah so
here I I I the Maya tutorial I have is
is really great I'm not going to spend a
ton of time on Maya here I've got a
custom character uh you know set up
use the tutorial that I have this is the
definition way that Maya does it it
gives you this map it will create a new
character definition and you would go
through and you would you would select
the hip and look here's the hip on my
guy right click assign
bone uh here's the spine Bones on my guy
I would like right click go down right
right click assign sign you build up the
map This Way shoulder
Bend be in here there's no Auto really
yeah certainly not for mixo what you can
do and I think I've given it out in the
Maya tutorial is if I have a character
and actually let's use um let's use the
same guy I've been using mixim rigged
guy Maya also has weird scale size
things that happen all the time it
doesn't really matter for retargeting
but if I were to create a character
definition this is a mixo character I
have a mixo preset I made so I did this
custom one time I hit okay it's done um
super easy the other thing I will say
about Maya that can get really confusing
is that it's got this weird name space
system so what I like to do in Maya is
if I were to import that mixim MO cap
take that we've been using because this
is a mixim mo character and it has the
similar named bones it would like freak
out um so what you can do is modify go
to the actually go to the windows tab
General editors name space
editors create a new name space add this
to it this is very Maya specific but for
Maya people if you run into name space
issues that's how you fix that then we
would go and we would go and import our
motion
capture um here we got our
map we're in the wrong FPS let's change
this to 24 we got our map what we would
do is we would go and we would create a
new character
definition for our map we would go and
either Define it manually or load in a
preset which I have then you just set
the character to your character the
source to your motion
capture and we've retargeted I have
really great tutorials about this
process on the YouTube channel I I
recommend going there if you want to
know more about how to do this in depth
Maya is like we could spend all day
going through this but the but Maya is
the best because what you can do in Maya
is once you've done this definition and
retargeting phase there's no ik control
rig that I've made for this character
but as long as you've done this
retargeting I can go I think it's off
screen but I have this option Bak yeah
it says bake to control rig it
automatically adds an ik control rig for
me it's so great I can delete my my moap
now Maya has a smoothing filter that's
really amazing if I select all of
my uh NS for my control rig I can go to
Windows animation editors graph editor I
could select all of these these these
graphs it has a Butterworth filter it
makes map look buttery smooth butter
worth dude I need that on everything it
I do I wish it was on everything and
then if you're doing that editing system
again it gives you an ik control rig
really easily you go to the channel box
layer editor tab up here it'll by
default open up in display but we go to
anim if I want to fix the clip thing I
grab my wrist I hit create layer from
selected it adds a new layer you can see
all my key frames are now gone right and
I can go
and start doing editing right uh the
same way that we've been doing in all
the other programs um amazing it just
comes with the ik rig for free Maya is
like incredible yeah it just it as long
as you've done the retargeting it like
knows which Bones you've put as the
wrist so it just it's so great and also
the undo button in Maya corrupts
corrupts projects like it's been a bug
for 30 years it hasn't been fixed my
look at this look at this UI it's like
insane Maya is the best and the worst
simultaneously um that's so funny
without a doubt it's the best for for
this I love it every program has its
Jank you know um which is you know you
can't get away from it can't get away
from the Jank that's as as VFX artists
3D artists we troubleshoot that's all we
do we troubleshoot a lot autodidacts
baby YouTube is your best friend yeah
get in that YouTube YouTube what was
that big word you used what was it what
does that mean autodidact it's like you
teach you teach yourselves things you're
able to teach yourself things okay yeah
yeah I've never heard that word before
and yeah CG is we're all autodidacts we
all everyone teaches themselves
everything in CG I found it's you know
we're all like amped everyone's so amped
and like down to explore and learn and
stuff and things change program versions
change every year and it's like you
gotta continuing education it's like
we're
Architects um yeah so that's Maya I I
think it's unless there's questions that
we could it's it's so deep yeah Jack D
says when you generate the rig through
the add-on the character position
changed and didn't match the positioning
of the motion
capture is that a Maya question I don't
know probably it's probably just like a
comment um I don't I don't know um
through the add-on what add-on I don't
know that was probably a blender
question
maybe the the reason that you get
differences slight differences I mean
the broad it should match broadly but
the thing about motion capture that's
really worth knowing regardless and this
is something at roko we're always
talking about because roko is a neral
motion capture which means it's
not the most accurate even if you're map
basically if we go and we um you're
saying you're saying versus like all the
cameras set up looking at the balls all
the camera right you do all the all the
cameras right and you get the most
perfect map ever of uh of smeagle Thanos
what's Josh Brolin doing um yeah doing
Thanos right yeah the thing is his map
his body is different
proportions than uh the map is than the
character is rather look at this
character this character has way shorter
legs in my motion capture it's got
differ sized arms it's got different
positions of the
shoulders you they will always have
differences between the motion capture
in the character that's relative to the
differences in the scale of the joints
between the skeletons right so if you
clap if Josh Brolin
claps and you get the most perfect moap
ever but then you retarget that onto
Thanos whose arms are two feet longer
than Josh Brolin's you know proportional
to his body thanos's map looks like this
now because his forearms are just longer
right so you get so a lot of the things
that you'll see where the map is is you
retarget it and the character looks
different slightly um it's because the
character's proportions are different
and you just get that's why you get foot
sliding often in blender you're going to
get foot sliding uh because the the hip
height relative to the ground is
different in the map and your character
like uh Maya is the only program where
you never get foot sliding it's just one
of the amazing things about Maya it's
because it's doing a million things in
the back end That You Don't See that
help with foot sliding unreal we're
going to run into foot sliding um every
other system you're going to have foot
sliding which is why it's nice to know
how to do map editing using ik control
rigs um I don't know if that answers the
question no no but that was good though
because that was not even something
that we talked about yet um yeah that
will be a thing yeah that's a thing we
can maybe get into in unreal with the
control rigs yep but um
let's
see I'm might open up unreal in the
meantime yeah go for it go for
it if you guys don't have any Maya okay
can you go over Maya retargeting once
again no I mean I it's like kind of
weird I would just go check out my
tutorial it's so it's l below it's link
below right it's going to be better than
this yeah it's linked below and again
you go to the Roco YouTube
channel and here it is actually um the
Maya one but if you go to the main
YouTube channel for
roko uh it's this is the playlist
ultimate retargeting workflows right
here and Maya is actually the first one
in it and I go through character
definition I go through fixing the name
space issue which can be a thing we go
through the retargeting then we go
through the control rig the whole deal
yeah so this is really this is great
it's actually one of the simpler ones
Maya
um but yeah so shall we get into unreal
here um how are you doing do you need a
break do you need I'm doing great man
okay cool yeah I'm good Do It Let's Do
It um I know I'm just talking am how's
my ramble after I feel like no no you're
good I'm keeping up and I think if I'm
keeping up then then so are people in in
the chat
um but I say that know how you guys
how's the chat do thumbs UPS if you guys
are hanging in you guys are enjoying
this thanking uh thankful for Sam being
here giving us all this good info
helping you guys make your art look good
um I'm GNA be doing live streams every
Thursday I do a live stream 11:00 a.m.
PST on Thursdays on the roko YouTube
channel we're going to spend every week
doing this project uh if people have
questions I will be there Live come and
ask we can get into it amazing to the
best of my ability you know that's
always the caveat because there's so
many things I don't know sweet no that's
great so yeah you got Thursdays on roko
I got Fridays here boom and we're all
just freaking helping each other out and
making awesome art I love it
dude um man we got we got some thumbs
UPS in chat guys I appreciate that nice
nice good stuff cool very good stuff
we're going to hit unreal right now
we're going to dive into here and uh
talk
about all the things we've been talking
about defining retargeting editing and
all the specific ways that it goes down
in unreal so mon could you move my big
head once again cuz like there's going
to be a lot of stuff going on down here
that my big old head is just going to be
blocking the whole time um we'll
do but uh yeah Sam you want to you want
to get into it yeah let me talk for
another 30 minutes straight I'm so sorry
I feel like water no I got water I've
had a boatload of coffee I'm good man
all
right yeah um no it's not a it's not a
complaint about how I'm feeling to
complain I just feel like I'm just
talking so much but guess that's good um
okay so unreal unreal is again I I I
know I keep saying this but we have to
we just put out a bunch of new two new
tutorials on the roko channel covering
retargeting and unreal they're an hour
long each one is for General retargeting
one is for metahumans and that's because
there
are a there are two main ways to do map
retargeting when it comes to Unreal and
so it's a little bit different than the
other programs so uh that's why they're
longer but there's so much good
information in there and there's also
links to some free resources that we're
going to be using um for control rigs
which is really cool unreal finally has
good control rig workflows which is
really awesome so I think we'll start by
just saying similar to the other
softwares we are not going to be using
this if we go to the template and we go
to the
sequencer right shift C to
uhoh shift C to to go to the camera and
the sequencer we're not going to be
using this guy as our map
base this guy is their I mainly as a
reference again I I might be wrong maybe
some people are using this animation
this guy right here to do your
retargeting to but what we're really
going to be doing and what we're going
to be doing right now is if we go into
the Eternal asent files in content and
we go down to
map here we have the moap hey Sam one
sec and it's one sec so we are lagging a
little bit stream
laging so maybe we hang for like a
minute or and we see if it doesn't fix
itself cuz this is good stuff that we
want to touch on um let's
see all right y'all
um see if the internet fixes itself stop
lagging
H come on YouTube
yeah I'm not getting the warning
anymore um I'm playing it just for
reference cool yeah you guys should be
seeing
smooth butter what is it
Butterworth Butterworth filter isn't
that a great name for smoothing filter
butter it sounds like it's very un Maya
it's it's like super cool I love it
Butterworth so
descriptive okay we're back we're back
um um we're in let's see what's time get
these chapters 125 19 let's do it so
we're in
unreal let's restart without the lag how
you doing we're in unreal okay and what
we're talking about is we are not using
what's in the scene to do our map
retargeting instead we're using if you
go into the Eternal Ascent files in
content there's this map folder and
Clint has already provided you with the
animation on uh the ue4 mannequin and
the ue5 mannequin now this animation
obviously has this weird you know moment
when it's adjusting to the spot you just
have to fix that and right we'll go
through that right but here's the
animation yeah it's already set up well
it won't be set up when we when we use
it on our character actually we're GNA
have to do this because this is the
animation we're going to be using now
the reason that it's so cool that this
animation is already on the ue4 and the
ue5 mannequins is that it means that
this is already compatible with any
character that is using a ue4 or ui5
mannequin skeleton now if you go to the
Epic Marketplace for example and you are
getting your character maybe you've made
ma your character um maybe you're using
a character you've purchased from the
Epic Marketplace maybe you're using a
character that you put purchase from
another Marketplace that was rigged with
the ue4 skeleton but any of the
characters and there's even free ones on
the
ue4 uh Market on the on the onreal
marketplace will be rigged to be
compatible with the ui4 UI 5 skeletons
you can see this if you go into the
character definition uh description here
usually rigged to Epic skeleton yes
right it'll tell you and if it is
already rigged to the Epic skeleton it
means we don't have to do a lot of that
retargeting stuff that we were doing in
the other programs we're going to talk
about how to retarget to a mixo
character which is not rigged to an epic
skeleton in a little bit but first let's
start with characters that are rigged to
the Epic skeleton so for example I have
got a character that I purchased on the
Epic
Marketplace looks super cool comes with
physics that already work right it's
very nice uh when you have a character
that is already made to work in unreal
now I have to tell this character that
it's compatible with the ue4 skeleton it
it is but we still have to tell it and
the way that I do that is I go and I
find the the uh skeletal mesh that I'll
be using I open it up it usually opens
up in this this window right here we're
going to go to the skeleton tab
and then under window asset
details we open up the asset details
panel and in here you can see we have a
slot compatible skeletons so there's
nothing in here right now but if I hit
add
element I can go and I'm going to select
the
ue4 mannequin skeleton that's what this
character is already compatible with I'm
going to slot it in I'm going to hit
save so how do you know if it's u4 or
u5 so uh um it should be both is ideally
uh it should be both uh no it it should
be listed on if you purchased the you
know character it's usually listed there
but you can just try both right and uh
and and just kind of go by trial by uh
you know just eliminate it
um Yep looks good and so what we can do
now is let me add this guy to our
scene boom in my in our
scene add it to our sequencer here you
have to move me again
Soo oh yeah sorry no no no yeah we're
going to be down here a
lot um but we'll add it to sequencer
Right add it into that template that
that we got and let's go to frame zero
and if we get there's an animation slot
right here let's hit plus look EA map
ue4 added and if we play it you can see
it's going to do that weird thing at the
beginning when it when it just so we're
just going to go by the way that is
simply for any simulations or motion
blur over the and also it wasn't on it
wasn't on frame yeah the positioning is
a little weird you'll just have to line
up the positioning that's all yeah we're
also going to have to because I just
threw my guy in but but then you can see
I just lined up the end of the animation
with the end of the template timeline
here right and he's locked in so that is
I mean perhaps you can we've gone
through all the other uh programs and
this is really
nice uh if you are obviously using a ue4
ue5 compatible skeleton that is much
simpler to do right look it's already in
place it already looks good we just have
to go in
and uh make sure this guy is actor
hidden in
game or delete him hey buddy
and look we got it done oh man alt uh
alt s to enable our physics boom working
s enables
physics uh I'm just
simulating alt s that's
cool yeah you can you can if you go up
to the um play yeah and then simulate is
just all s i I'm such a noob when it
comes to Unreal as well I'm sure I'm
doing things weird wrong but um no
that's huge that's that's amazing so
what do you what do you well it'll play
when you use the movie render queue
it'll simulate so this is just a way to
simulate beforehand yeah um clipping how
do we deal with clipping clipping okay
yes okay great question
so okay so now we're getting into it
here so okay there's the first way to do
this remember we talked about FK versus
ik yeah ideally what we want is an ik
control rig now epic provides on the
Epic store if you go and you search
for uh let's go
to control
rig we'll get this control rig mannequin
ue4 um this control rig only works for
your mannequin it doesn't work for a
character um it's weird it is weird it's
unfortunate the ue5 one should work like
for the mannequin and your character cuz
it's more procedural but that's okay
because we have an ik control rig asset
and this is this is going to if this is
confusing again it's all in the tutorial
I know I keep saying that but it just I
I don't you know link below yeah I go
yeah link below um but but let's say we
we want to do it FK it's easy to do FK
and that requires no control rig and we
just want to move this arm so it isn't
clipping that's easy what we're going to
do is in sequencer I've got my character
here for some reason it's named ue4
mannequin skeleton but whatever it's
it's here's my character I've got it
selected if I rightclick on my
character um I can go to and where is
this oh golly Ed it with FK yeah okay so
I'm going to right click on my character
and go to edit with FK control rig I'm
going to click it and what this is going
to do is it's going to bake all this
animation for the length of our timeline
no more than the length of our timeline
very important it will only do the
In-N-Out point on the sequencer timeline
that's what it's doing I'm going to hit
create and look it gave us this FK
control rig that now and and unreal 5
has this whole new animation mode layout
where here we've got our rig here look
if I want to grab my this arm upper
arm oh no upper arm left that's the left
one and I want to change it look we can
change it again look at I've have
already got key frames on this upper arm
so if I make a change nothing's going to
happen we need to add that layer again
right again these these systems are the
same in everything it's just how you do
it is different so we need to on the FK
control rig right here Plus
additive so ad TR we have additive track
same deal right we've got a layer it's
got no key frames on it that means that
we can do additive
animation Boop add a key
frame beautiful wait did it did it work
so yeah it's yeah it's it's changed if
we want to do um you know do key frame
over time there we we go now the arm
should like go
up so there you go so that's the
principle to do map editing when it
comes to FK right again which is kind of
annoying let's say we want to fix these
and the great thing about this layer
system is always of course I can delete
this layer if things go terribly wrong
and like the reset which is always so
nice um let me hold on I want
to okay yeah no key frames on here so
but let's say I want to
fix um my foot
sliding which I have very slight foot
sliding because this character is very
close to the original moap but you can
see there is foot sliding or or maybe
I've got a rock here in my scene and
right I need to adjust the position of
the of the foot well going FK is going
to be pretty annoying because we're
gonna have to go okay there's a big rock
right here so when this foot lands I
need to okay I'm going to do this and
I'm going to move the thigh up and then
I'm going to have to go and find the
calf and set a key frame for the calf
and as this goes up I need to rotate it
back down and set a to totally doable
just annoying right not ideal so not
ideal what you want is an ik control rig
system so let's delete this
layer FK
and I'm actually going to have to just
delete this and drag him back shift one
to go back to this normal mode here I'm
going to I deleted him out of sequencer
because it just got messy I'm going to
re him back into
sequencer I'm going to read the mo
cap I'm going
to uh sorry I need to go and make my guy
visible again
and so I can position my fellow in the
right
spot I'm just doing the same thing we
did at the
beginning to add the motion capture to
my guy put him in the right spot right
let's get him in here here we go great
looks good yeah he's in the right spot
boom looks awesome um okay so now what
we're going to go
do is use a control rig that is free um
it was made by a roko Discord Alberto
Flores super nice he made this amazing
control rig asset that you can use to
add to any ue4 compatible character and
it and it automatically works with any
ue4 compatible character so following
the workflow that we've done so far um
you can find this download it's azip
it's in the Roco tutorial
yeah it's link below yeah it'll give you
this folder and what we're going to do
is we are going to go and add this
folder uh we're going to go show in
Explorer this is the folder of my
project that I'm working in right now
right this is the content folder of the
project I'm I'm currently in I'm just
going to add the Roco resources folder
in here into content cool into
content uh as soon as I do that do I
have two versions of this
open Jesus um but as soon as I do that
you can see Roco resources we got this
folder in here and we've got this
mannequin control rig Auto setup um so
I'm just opening it up I I like to open
it up compile it just to make sure
everything's working correctly I
probably shouldn't have hit save now we
have to wait for it to save
by the way guys if you have any um tips
that we're not hitting right now or any
like hey this is good to know leave it
as a comment in this in this video
please leave it as a comment cuz I want
this to be a great resource for people
to Branch off from and go find the
answers to their problems um so please
do that I see a lot of helpful stuff
here in in chat so if you leave it as a
comment that'll be very very helpful
guys I appreciate it um
sweet we're good to go we're compiled
good to go we're compiled so we've got
this resources folder added and again
because this is a ue4 compatible
character now when I rightclick on my
character and sequencer and I go to bake
to control rig look I've got this
mannequin control
rig I can bake to and I'm going to
create it does the same thing it bakes
it down right and look at what it did it
automatically added all of these
NS this is the one fabrio used right or
was it another
one this is not but it's similar um this
is for ue4 compatible characters right
the one that Fazio used was a mixim
control rig one which we're going to
talk about when we do this for a miimo
character but same same deal right I've
got ik controls so great if I want to do
actual edits I don't like these key
frames right we got to add that additive
layer this is my mannequin control rig
layer let's hit plus additive let make
sure that it's the entire time here and
now I can go in and I can
start doing much
easier uh edits so I got this foot and
I've got a rock in my scene that he
steps on actually boom just move that up
at a key frame so easy and then go back
look it it's it sits right there and
okay at the second one there is no Rock
so I need to have it go back add a key
frame go copy this original key frame oh
I cut it that was not
good right click copy
paste so way easier that would be a rock
right and then it goes back to normal
so so much easier using ik control rigs
whenever you can to
do um things that that that are that are
custom for your editing right and again
if I don't like any of this I can always
just delete these and I've got the
original amazing animation yeah super
cool um there's also a function in this
particular control rig I'm not going to
show it off because I want to get to
your project and playing around and we
still have more unreal stuff to go
through in a second but you can can
slave the left and right uh hands
together so really cool if you wanted to
have a character waving a flag you can
just animate the left hand waving and
then slave the right hand to it and it
will just follow go check out the
tutorial for how to do that it's it's
really cool and easy and it's a unique
feature of this control rig sweet okay
so that's
ui4 um is it ui5 time how do you feel
yeah U is the same deal uh it's same and
when I say by the way when I say ui4 u5
obviously we're in ui5 right now yes
we're talking ui4 mannequins u4 rigs
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um let me
delete this delete this delete this um
yeah if I had a
ue5 um compatible character instead I
would just go when I'm setting up my
mesh in that asset details panel I just
would set this to be the it's kind of
hard to see them but this is the ue4 one
this is the ue5 one I would just set it
to say hey you're compatible with the u5
one and then when you go into sequencer
you'll
see
this animation show up so it's it's the
same process if you have characters that
are compatible with the ue4 or the ue5
skeleton really makes it easy and unreal
if you are working with characters that
are already compatible to these
skeletons and the way that they're like
in unreal the reason that you have this
system of
compatibility is because it's a game
engine right so like on the unreal
Marketplace there's tons of assets that
are animation assets firstperson shooter
whatever so it's all set up so that all
those animations are done on the
mannequin and that's why so many
characters are natively compatible with
the mannequins because it means that if
you're playing if you're setting up a
game I can just use these animation
assets from the mannequin on my
character it's very circular I know when
I'm talking it can get really confusing
but no no no I'm following 100% okay
yeah no worries cool um so do we want to
do a a u5 character and show the control
rig there like get people as far as that
or what what what do you want to do I
think it's better to look at how we
would do a mixim character because a
miimo character is a is a different way
of doing this so so let's go and we're
going to go grab that same mixo
character and we create a
folder mixo
character and I'm going to go import
that same fellow that we were
using uh Taurus miimo uh mixo rigged
when I'm importing it I want to import
the mesh right I don't need any
animations import
all so here I've now got oh God it's
like a different size so this is a whole
thing should be okay oh no it was the
right size um but here I've got my mixo
character now obviously this character
it has a miimo skeleton and not only
that it it's in a te- pose so very
different from your unreal
characters the way that we do
retargeting to custom characters that
are not compatible with the u4 ue5
mannequin is by using the ik retargeting
system now this is a new system in
unreal it makes it easier than ever to
do retargeting in unreal but it is a
little Annoying especially compared to
the plug- Inplay system that we just
looked at but it is very doable and the
way that we're going to do
this is we are going to rightclick in
our characters folder and we're going to
go to we're just going to search for
ik you can just right click and then
search for ik right we want to create an
ik rig I'm going to name this rig
ik miimo character I like to put ik in
there so that I can find it to search in
the search bar but we're going to create
this
ik asset
here now this is what it looks like when
I open up that ik
asset and under preview skeleton mesh
I'm going to add my mixim
character yeah here we go and what we're
going to do now is a process and you
might want to move Clint down now cuz
we're going to be up in this left
quadrant now yeah Soo if you can move me
scoop my booty oh no this is a more
annoying process but it's also easier
than it's ever been so it's a bit of a
mixed bag but basically what we need to
do is we're going back to that character
definition stage right remember that
character definition stage and all the
other programs stage one same thing in
unreal right stage one we need to tell
unreal hey these bones are these bones
so the way that we do that in unreal is
for the hips we've got our our whole
skeleton uh hierarchy here I'm going to
right click on the hips set retarget
root so this is the root bone for our
character then I'm going to go to all my
spine bones I'm going to shift click
select all my spine bones right click
new retarget chain get this popup chain
name spine that's what we want add chain
and now we've added a chain down here in
this ik retargeting panel it says the
the name of the chain which is spine it
says the start bone and the end bone
right and we're going to go in now we're
going to select the neck and the head
new retarget chain head we got a new
chain then we're going to do the left
arm left shoulder shoulder down to the
left arm and so these are these are all
the different chains in your character
right we got the spine we got the neck
we got the left arm we got the right arm
we got the left leg we got the right leg
new retarget chain left arm add
chain I'm not going to do it for the
hand the fingers because I don't want to
right now we're trying to move a little
faster I'm going to do it for the right
arm new retarget chain right arm if you
do do it for the fingers it has a
tendency to not name them correctly see
this is the middle finger but it doesn't
say left middle it says left arm so you
might need to go in and you're doing the
fingers like type in left middle and
I'll talk about why we're naming them
this way in a second but now I'll do the
left leg which is the left up leg all
the way down to the left toes new
retarget chain left leg and we'll do the
right
leg new retarget chain add chain so we
got these chains that we just created
and for the hip we set as retarget root
MH so this is now done we're going to
save this and the great
thing a little bit about what is already
in this project file for you is that if
we go to characters and we go to ue4
Manakin there's already that ik rig set
up for you and this is remember the map
is on this guy so we we need to tell
unreal to find this guy Define our
character so that during retargeting
unreal knows hey left arm to left arm
right right arm to right arm we we need
we're telling it how to do this process
now this is already set up for us but
the way that unreal does it is a little
bit
different it only does for the left arm
from the upper arm to the hand so I'm
going to go in and do it from the
shoulder the clavicle bone I'm going to
change this on the left arm for the
right arm I'm going to change it to the
right clavicle so I'm and again I'm
moving fast tutorial link down below um
I I'm I'm changing the right and left
arms because and then I'm there's a
bunch of twist bones I'm deleting all
these twist bones we don't need these
there's actual clavical dedicated chains
don't need those so once I've deleted
those I've made uh changes to the left
and right Arms This Is Now set up I
don't need to go and Define each each
bone and that brings us we've now
defined our map we've defined our
character right so now we're going to go
and we're going to create an ik
retargeter asset
okay boom so you've set up the character
in the map to be speaking the same
language and then this is going to be
the bridge
Yep this is the retargeting time yes
exactly so we open this guy up and
Source remember it's the same
nomenclature from the other program
source and Target source is your moap
target is your character so source is
going to be our ik
ue4 guy right remember the map is
already in our project on this guy we
could use the five as well it doesn't
matter I'm just going to use the four
and then our Target is our miimo
character now they come in on top of
each other you can use this target mesh
offset to just make them be side by side
and if we go to chain mapping
you can see same thing that we had in
blender right we got our source chains
and our Target chains and so it's nice
when these are remember when we were
setting up our our mixo character and it
was like spine head left arm these if
these match it will automatically be set
up together but you could always go in
and change these if you needed to but
but basically these chains are talking
to each other they are defined and
they're talking to each other and that
means means that under asset browser you
can see we have this EA moap which is
the moap for the for the the contest
double click it look it's it's working
it's retargeting now some things are
wrong
here look at how weird this looks okay
and that's because if we notice I mean
class what do we notice about these two
things one is not like the other one is
not like the other right this is why
it's so important for us to both be in a
t pose because this animation is being
copied but the relative differences
between the base
poses are are throughout the entire
animation right yeah so what we need to
do is just correct this and what we can
do is we go up here and these three
little hamburger
dots edit retarget pose we're going to
go to Source I like doing it on source
source means this this guy and I'm just
going to go and I'm going to move his
arm into a t- pose a little bit annoying
to do sorry for the fast
motions but let's put him in a t pose do
the same thing
for the upper
arm and I wish that we didn't have to do
this stuff but this is just the way that
it works in uh in unreal it's a little
bit messy uh and I'm also going to move
These Arms forward a little bit okay I'm
eyeballing this but you know you can get
more deep and
um again I go through it in the in the
tutorial a little bit but um can you
move the the feet together a little bit
to yeah I could I would I want them to
match so it looks like on our character
they are a little bit closer so I might
I'm going to turn off snapping and just
like maybe I'll make this a little bit
closer the closer they are the more
accurate it this system is going to work
so like you can see there are
differences here in the hands I should
be going in and doing this too I'm just
not going to right now cuz I don't think
we need to for the purposes of this but
the the the map will be different by the
amount that these are different right
it's all relative to the base pose but
anyway now that we've done
this
oh here we go done yeah so generally
looks way better right obviously we
didn't do the fingers for time yeah I
didn't do the fingers remember you'd
have to go in and and make those finger
chains yeah in the ik rig super annoying
you only have to do it once though and
it just is what it is
and sweet yeah I mean this is you know
why I think a lot of people who use
unreal they're they're also blender
users they're also Cinema users and
maybe you do your
retargeting in those programs and you
bring it over right if you don't want to
deal with this this isn't that bad um
but it's you can see it's a little so
annoying yeah we this get in we yeah
yeah what we do from here is we select
this animation and we have to export
selected animations I'm just going to
export it to my top content
folder there we go you can see if I pull
it up look I got my animation on my guy
and at this point we're going to follow
that same process we normally do we are
going to drag our mixim Mo character
into the scene how do you know the
difference between those three of the
same looking dudes you know what I mean
go back to your content browser your
characters oh yeah yeah yeah how do like
I always get mixed up like they're the
same to me yeah so they are the same in
a lot of ways they're different the way
that you can think about these is
they're different uh sides to the same
mesh so if we open up this one the the
difference is
let me let me go here it will open this
up you can see that we're in the
skeletal mesh tab if we click on
this that is just opening up this one
the skeleton one see skeletal mesh
skeleton and then this one is the
physics one so if we click on the I'm
off screen if we click on this
tab that would be the same as if we
opened up Al so it's all the same but
just different windows it's just
different it's different tabs of the
same model and you do different things
in in right here there's an animation
tab um so how do you know like which
one's the right one to drag in uh the
one to drag in is uh not the physics one
you can usually do either the skeleton
or the skeletal mesh I always do the
skeletal mesh the skeletal mesh is the
most one that's just like your model
with there's like a skeleton in there
there but it's the it's just the it's
the it's the overarching one essentially
I don't yeah that's good to know so I
drag in that one but I could I could
probably drag in the physics one it
wouldn't matter um but once we drag it
in I add it to my
sequencer I go to plus animation look
here's the exported animation from the
ik
retargeter and we do the same thing we
did before mhm there we go and we'd have
to go and um where is that
guy match it up match it
up and then you could do the whole
additive stuff as well and then we could
do the whole additive stuff uh with the
FK um or because this is a mixim
character there is actually a mixo ik
control rig and you can see this guy's
got super long legs so we got like
real differences Happening Here on these
stairs right um which again we could
always move the stair or the object up
to match but let's say we wanted to do
ik retargeting on this guy there is
a uh and this is linked in the
description from Gabriel paa pava uh on
Art station a mixim based control rig so
if I drag so here it is this is I
downloaded the zip right it gave me this
folder if I drag this into our content
folder like I dragged that roko
resources folder in
yeah oh no Auto SAE well good there we
go um because this is a mixim mo
character we used go back to my content
browser control rig folder this is the
folder we just Dragged In you can see if
I can open up this mixo control rig take
a hot second for it to open hopefully it
didn't crash here it goes
in the preview
scene I can just
select my mixo
character and look at this oh mama ik oh
wow control rig this I
found really only works for characters
that like you directly like this
character went I downloaded from mixo
and imported it right in yeah I've I've
pulled it into Cinema and then exported
it from Cinema and then tried to pull it
into here and like something changed
with the the naming convention somewhere
along the way so sometimes it like won't
work automatically but if you're pulling
it directly from mixo it will just
automatically work which is so freaking
crazy because then same way we did with
the uh the ue4 skeleton control rig I
can right click bake to control rig why
is it not showing
up I can uncheck this filter asset by
skeleton if it doesn't show up for
whatever reason mixo control
rig bake it and then we do our additive
layer right
sweet make sure that this layer is long
and now we got those we got weird
leggies happening right so let's go in
and fix
those this guy right here so let's add a
key frame
boom oh dude yes so amazing really
incredible and this is a shout out to
Fabrizio Moray winner of two of the
Clint challenges the only one one
two he showed me how this works um
that's sick uh super super cool and this
is a free asset thank you Gabriel paa
whoever you are Distributing free
control rigs so awesome so all the same
things we talked about apply here
amazing there you go that's it dud all
right look I'm going to switch I'm going
to switch us back to a little full
screen
situation
oh that was that was crazy you just got
the I know it's a lot dude yeah that's
it though that's like that's the
freaking stream for the ages because we
touched on blender we touched on c4d we
touched on Maya we touched on unreal
both UEI the ue4 um mannequin or
skeleton rather also applies to ue5 and
the miimo a miimo
skeleton
um holy crap uh we talked on what is it
uh defining the three steps to
retargeting Define retarget and then
edit and we talked about that oh not we
let's be honest here guys Sam schooled
us all today um merch coming soon Define
retarget edit yes I want to see it dude
that's a a good one yeah um do you want
to do let's see we're at the point now
where I think I think a a push-up break
a jumping jack break of some sort could
help um shake up Shake the bones a
little bit and um hyck break Dude down
you want to you want to play some hacky
sack got my got my mograph the cograph
yes yeah boy all right so I'm so
terrible at it but we'll try you got
your hackey sack shoes on
I
don't all right I'm going bar I got my
slippers on actually maybe I'll do on my
slippies here's what we'll do we'll
leave it to chat um yeah push-ups or
hacky yeah what let's see let's do a
poll and then I think we'll just take I
don't
know
15 let's let's take okay how about this
we'll
take a turn each um I'll start cuz you
did a lot of talking um um not that
that's a bad thing you just need a break
you need a break I'll I'll take the ball
here for a second and show off my unreal
scene um where I'm at in my render and
then we'll pass it and try to get a
character you should try to get a
character and see if you remember we
just talked about and if you have
questions let's go through it let's try
and like get a character into your scene
use a control rig yes and like see you
do it perfect okay that sounds good and
then we'll switch over to you see where
you're at like you're working on Art too
for this aren't you yeah I don't really
have much to show I mean besides getting
8 million MOA characters it's cool you
just we could exit or we could close it
out on that to show us where you're at
and like what you're thinking maybe you
don't have to if you don't want to it's
all good i' love to I love you I yeah
I'll use my time like I'm a I mean I
don't think I'll I can win but I but I
uh just because I'm a part of the
company that's helping the sponsor but
but I want to I want to be I've never
made top 100 I'm want it I got you so
I'm just going to abuse my yeah position
to get advice from you perfect perfect
all right so here's what we're going to
do
um let's put a poll to chat and
see what workouts we want to
do um all right what
workout shall we do question mark okay
we got throw me some suggest some
suggestions what do you got uh push-ups
that's one
right squats
push-ups uh squats are good I could use
some squats how about like could
stretching be in
there Mobility yeah yoga let's do
some or hacky
sack
umy and I'm going to start this poll
cuz we need it we've been sitting here
for 2
hours um yeah I
know I I got to say man I my um I like
I'm pretty good with my posture or the
way that I normally sit at my desk but
when I'm working on trying to get my
stairs looking right for Eternal Ascent
the last few nights I like I must to
like Lean Forward yeah a terrible way
hunch dude like hurt's my back in the
back of your
no neck it's like over your
head yeah it's not good yeah we need it
posture is everything all right here
let's just do this do you have a
standing desk or or can you where you at
okay I don't I can kind of get a little
uh little heart opener get the I can do
one of these
going oh chest oh
boy everyone everyone on stream at this
point sorry SoDo hopefully I'm not sping
up that no you're good you're good join
us in these stretches join us in these
workouts we've all all been sitting down
for the last two hours let's do a little
stretchy
stretch oh yeah little uh side
stretch yeah dude I'm
not just I can't believe it's been 5
years since 2000s like I'm getting so
old I know just two 1999 was five years
ago can you believe that wait what what'
you say in my head
it's it's 99 man that's funny imagine we
just did this for the whole stream just
two grown men just stretching like this
just generally stretching
good all right um the chat has spoken
they want push-ups and then I think we
can get some hacky sack after that and
then we'll get into uh some art and then
we'll close out yeah um what kind of
push-ups do you want to do you want to
do tricep push-ups do you want to do the
hardest push-ups normal no I can't do
diamond push-ups I got to do my normal
wide all right what what I was doing a I
tried to I was trying to do a 100 a day
for a little while that thing and which
I could not I mean I just I can do but
it's I yeah that's um what's his name
freaking that anime everyone yeah it's
like a thing I think I think it's just a
good goal it's a great goal I'm trying
to do 50 a day now I I I that I'm not
cocky I do not have good form I'm not
you call the number tell us what's the
number we're doing
them like 12 okay 12 man we're doing 12
um you guys join us let's do 12 all
right I'll I'll see you back here and
then we'll we'll do hacky attack 12 push
okay let's do it good
be
hey yep yep um for those of you in chat
who joined us on those push-ups let me
get a thumbs up please I want to see oh
you know what Give me the give me the
the the the muscle the arm give me
something let me see where yall at where
my push-up people at uh we got hacky
sack next let me throw
on my shoes cuz it's impossible without
shoes well yeah I'll be right
back I my
slippers cozy fuzzy slippers here I will
entertain let's see if I was watching
Clint do this on the stream last week
and he's so
good at it it's just a lot a lot of
practice man um every day I would try
and wake up and play hacky sack for a
little
bit for
Lego all right I'm me see if I get see
how many things I can see knock over
30 I can get
no it's hard dude it's hard so
hard I just need a soccer
ball 15 not bad four four Four's good
dude Four's good all right here let's
keep keep it up keep up that that blood
flow
that's Prett
good
[Music]
oh all right good sesh good
sesh yeah good
sesh all right I feel um re rejuvenated
yeah yeah let's see if I can get a
character in my UI scene let's see if I
can take what Sam learned or taught me
and uh apply apply it um all right let
me reconfigure all right get back
so
okay all
righty bo
bo just doing a little reconfiguring
dude
this I'm watching this live stream right
now it's just us playing hacky sck is
the goofiest looking I know that's so
funny
I'm just pleased I didn't knock over
like water all over my computer that's
that's a good move yeah good move um all
right let's hop in let's do it man let's
see what you got okay teacher is
watching
so um oh let me move this one so I'm
bringing this over to my main screen
just so I there's not an Infinity just a
heads up
sure um all
right
so this this is the scene I got so far
looking awesome man yeah I got like this
um that is that easy fog for the what's
the deal with the clouds No it's just
like VDB Cloud pack thing oh cool um
what was that shortcut for hopping into
the camera and out of the camera oh man
shift
c yeah
yeah I know right that's that one's good
that's a good one you have to be in you
have to have the sequencer selected or
something so sometimes it won't work
like if you're in the content tab yeah
but yeah these are so these are my
photos scan Mountains from that video
where I was like how to photo scan a
mountain um kit bash assets here I'm
playing with like these different things
little kit bash pirate pack
um yeah cargo is amazing I don't want to
like it's the best I won't but K bash is
great I'm okay brown nose and kit bash
they're awesome they're so lovely cargo
is actually really cool I the very first
version of it you you had to import that
test Castle which was super annoying but
now they fixed that it's like so it's so
great it's insane I love it yeah like
they're adding Vehicles the Interiors
like you can grab like any anything so
like this Enchanted Castle mhm
download and then you make sure that
like you're unreal is referencing it
boom you turn the cargo light on Bing
and then yeah you should be able to just
like once this is done
downloading do a little bit of by the
way guys you can youall get 20% off
cargo um yeah right now with the link in
the description
jump on it now when you got the discount
yeah cargo Pro and that should pop in
here we should have a giant castle up
here um
momentarily it should be
importing yeah it takes a second
sometimes or whatever
but it's so great I love how I always
thought think thought of Kit bash for
big buildings but they have like barrels
you know like I go to quicko and you so
often you
want something that you see in the
collections photo that they have on
quickel you know and then it's like
there isn't the thing and um this has so
many good like yes like these little
guys amps like they have a whole they
have good they have every instrument is
on cargo great I don't they have one gun
guns we'll see how long this takes to
import but
um
shoot so yeah you know like the this
like giant grassland is literally one
mesh from quickel it's called like the
they have a couple of these and they've
been adding them recently these giant
Fields um or these massive scans this
thing back here all these mountains same
deal it's just one photo
scan um from quickel it's ridiculous I'm
using uh what do you call it uh Ultra
Dynamic Sky plugin for the lighting up
here um these vdbs are like uh they're
just like Cloud V generic cloud vdbs
and um I'm using like I figured out how
to do that uh with like the heterogenous
volume it's so such a weird name um um
but I followed some wind Bush tutorials
to get that going and I'm writing a
whole list of like I had this
troubleshooting log going I I started
doing this where like every project I
when I run into a problem I will write
the problem and then the answer and then
it helps me write tutorials and it also
just helps me like troubleshoot my own
crap when I'm like five projects ahead
like how you know I solved that problem
in five projects ago but but then since
I have a log of it you know I can just
boom it's right here there's the answer
that's that's great that's very
organized of you I just started doing it
like a couple projects ago and it's it's
a game changer for sure all right cuz I
imported it twice it's importing twice
now of course um what else other things
to
mention um what is so what is your uh
what is the the moap what's the guy
what's the deal like the character which
character am I going to do I'm going to
I'm going to try and bring in the pirate
just as a test yeah yeah
so I wish this was easier to like find
your stuff um pirate oh you can yeah you
can yeah it's also a good uh if you go
to category you can just select
characters okay cool got it oh he
already exist I already brought them in
right so that's how you do it you go to
your library you add them to your
project you choose the project right um
but since he's already
added all right material
assigning material 01 02 yeah and again
any any I mean there's a lot of usually
on the marketplaces if you're getting
your characters on the marketplaces
sometimes they'll say game ready usually
what that means is that they are
rigged it's either an unreal or Unity
skeleton often times there will be an
unreal skeleton and although you won't
be able to add it from the Epic Launcher
the way that you just add of that pirate
which is very nice you can import it and
it should work with the UI 4 mannequin
workflow or the ue5 mannequin workflow
and that control rig that should all
that should all work and then anything
from the marketplace will work almost
definitely with the map that you've
already that you know it all worked
natively in the first example that we
went through which is
um same thing with metahumans they they
work natively with the ue5 mannequin
meta humans yeah that's good to
know yeah all right if this thing
doesn't import just cuz we're on stream
right now force quit a force quit you
can switch to mine you want you want to
see mine yeah let's do that let's do
that let's flip over um all right we're
ready for you whenever you're ready I'm
up I'm up baby let's do it oo I mean
this is the most well whoa I mean
speaking of cargo this is one cargo
asset that I dropped in
so what my plan is is I am going to and
maybe you can tell me if this is allowed
I think it is I want to extend these
stairs out so they there's a wider bit
around here so I think the the main
thing is to maintain the um yeah the
what is it called the uh visual weight
so exactly I wouldn't go too far out
with them but I do think just a little
bit more maybe a little bit is cool like
I'd say within as long as long as you're
staying within like 80% is of like the
vibe um but yeah people are filling it
out in nice ways they're making it
unique to themselves as long as they're
not going like completely off to the
left side of frame you know um totally I
think there's a little wiggle room there
yeah okay good to know this is why this
is the reason I agreed to the stream is
just I
want but yeah I'm going to so I'm going
to have it's like a a guy but then
there's is going to be someone up front
like protecting him from guys coming
down the stairs that's kind of what I
got and then yeah kind of a Warhammer
Vibe I
think I love it got some cool monk guys
so that's my plan are you um are you
what are your plans for the
background um I think like just I'm a
lot of cargo has these amazing Neo I'm
kind of the my my main reference is from
the new uh Space Marine 2 trailer that
came out which is so amazing okay um but
it's just
like it's they're fighting among the
ruins of these Neo Victorian kind of um
ruins and so uh on cargo has these uh
oh cargo has this uh Neo Victorian and
Victorian kind of here let me go off the
side
um so I think I'm just going to grabb a
bunch of those and then Ultra Dynamic
sky is so freaking amazing it's the best
um and uh fer foucher I never know how
to say his name
amazing yeah the are unreal God easy fog
and just fill it up with a bunch of
maybe it'll be snowing oh Ultra dnamic
sky has Ultra dnamic weather too which
is really super cool um yeah a lot of
these type of
towers
I think in the background this kind of
vibe let me get your screen back yeah
there you are cool yeah I love it I love
it yeah this this kind of thing oh sick
dude it reminds me of like a dark souls
a little bit of Dark Souls going exactly
yeah that's that's the that's kind of
the the vibe yeah Dark Souls yeah so I
don't know I think that'll be good the
moap uh I got handled yeah but it's the
uh the rest of it yeah um let me see
dude I think I imported like freaking
three of the same thing you imported the
big yeah I imported the biggest one
three times on accident
so well here I will I can I can keep
things I'm using so I'm going to use
this let's say I wanted to get a guy in
from my library um where is my and I
want to add it to EA
Sam and I've got this cool heretic guy I
think this is going to be my main dude
um man so much respect for people out
there who are creating their own
characters I am such a generalist I'm
such a you know I I I'm a make a collage
of other people's work which is fine you
know um but I always have so much
respect for people who are doing making
their own characters and rigging them
from scratch it's crazy I I just don't
like I'm not made that way hey Sam Sam
Sam when you guys can you say when
you're announcing the winners of the
roko
challenge um I think it's next week
because yeah thank you we just had the
our judging panel with you and Ian and
Tim uh Tim Fox which was awesome Ian
always a blast um and yeah so it should
be next week and then we're going to do
best breakdown and Community favorites
after we've announced the the um the
best render God there were so many good
ones it was so cool thank you anyone In
This Crowd
we spent like we spent an extra like
hour just on the top five like from top
eight to top five like an hour just
figuring that out it was it was painful
which was so nice that there were so
many incredible submissions but man I
did not envy you guys it was really hard
hard yeah all right so what are you
doing you bringing your skeletal mesh
okay so I yeah I I went and I you know
went to my skeleton tab assigned asset
details right you're going to this is a
good refresher for you you're about to
do this I'm about to do it yeah my
skeleton uh ue4 which you can kind of
see that the ui4 one is like it's kind
of got a white material on it and the
ui5 has a silver so I always you want to
grab the ui4 for this character that I'm
using save it and I can close this out
I'm adding him into my
scene shift C oh so
great uh to get out of that camera view
and now I'm going to add him into
sequencer hit
plus add in that EA moap
ue4 super easy right boom set it up then
I just have to move him into
position let's just if I let's we'll set
up some Ultra Dynamic Sky we'll get it
going here in a second we'll make this
look cool yeah but here we go this
should look okay let's let's move him up
a little
bit looks pretty good like this I think
yep um I'm going to grab my template guy
I'm going to make him hidden I'm also
going to go
hidden uh hidden in game so that when I
simulate it it he will he will actually
be hidden um another good thing in
unreal that that took me a very long
time to figure out actually I'm going to
replace this guy with another version of
the heretic you just do that you can
just replace the
character oh we have to move it yeah
yeah I well he's got he's got a couple
different versions uh of him yeah no no
no but what I can do is also a good
keyboard shortcut to know control e just
opens up the editor for that
character I don't want this cape on my
character so I'm going to go down to if
you ever want to remove parts of a
character in unreal it can be kind of
tricky because it's usually one it's not
like in cinema where you have a bunch of
different separated meshes you want to
do in unreal which this is not news to
many people I'm sure but you go up to
the skeletal mesh tab right here we're
in skeletal mesh here you can see all
the different materials we can highlight
but if I want to enable or disable one
of these sections
here is the the hood for
example disable that I don't want that
hood I also don't want
this is this is this helpful very yeah I
know it took me so long to figure this
out and then you can right click disable
and now in this mesh those things are
gone so helpful so helpful thank you
yeah um and I'm hitting saving packages
so now I'm going to be in a save state
for I'll switch we'll switch to me we'll
switch to me yeah switch to you switch
to you okay all right let's
uh let's do this all right so wait what
oh God
dang just crashed no it's just still
going cuz I like I imported 30 I thought
I was like I I imported three of the
same one I thought I was good to go okay
well mine's done okay all right
switching back to you here we go
freaking funny okay so we got our we got
our gu
shift C look at this it's looking pretty
cool that's amazing so I think I'm G to
have him be
holding um a
flaming uh like um Talisman thing he'll
be holding so two hands together which
I'm going to use the control rig
workflow to set up to move the hands
into position and then he's going to be
holding like this thing so he's like a
religious dude and there's people coming
down the stairs that get knocked off um
by his protector guy try get some Ultra
Dynamic sky
going yeah let's do some Ultra Dynamic
Sky baby I hadn't you used Williams fog
stuff does it work with the UDS well oh
man it's so I'm gonna I'm GNA add it in
right now let's let's go I hate let's go
I hate that hate how we're all saying
let's go now it is overused I get it
yeah I'm gonna grab easy fog it is
overused man let's
party um but the way the easy fog Works
which is so freaking cool so here's easy
fog and I'm going to go back to
sequencer uh shift C get out of that
thing um but I go to easy fog and I go
to Blueprints and it all works off with
this blueprint system and you just drag
this thing in and it's just a this is it
what it's F cards that's literally it's
just F card it's an animated fog card so
you just go in and you it's so amazing
and you just you know I got to move
this what I've been doing actually now
too here's another hot tip I don't know
if they're hot tips but it's something
that I've been doing um go to the
hamburger and if I go to um layouts to
pain I want this pain to be my
perspective and then this pain can be my
thing and then I can go in and dude you
know move this around and it just makes
it really easy such a good technique
good workflow let let's add our our
Ultra Dynamic
Sky another blueprint based deal so
William fet's easy fog is specifically
for animated 2D fog cards it's it that's
all it is it's animated 2D fog cards
it's really great and there's he has
wind settings it's just noise um you
know it's just
noise uh things uh noise get animated
noise on on a card and it just uh it
it's super cool it just works really
really
well and then I love Ultra Dynamic
weather this [__] blows my mind excuse
me I use bad word oh no potty language
is is allowed in moderation I know potty
language po language okay Ultra dnamic
weather let's have this
be I love the snow it looks so freaking
cool is it snowing can you get like cuz
like Ultra dnamic weather goes the extra
level right cuz can't you have snow
accumulate on the ground and
stuff you can I have not figured all
that stuff out um cuz it's it gets
pretty deep they have great tutorials um
dnamic sky and it it comes with ultra
dnamic weather um it's so great if if
people are looking for um or just an
easy way to kind
of get stuff in their
scene on
target where are
you wait by moving that it changes the
direction of uh you can you can have it
set up that way oh God screwed it up
though oh finally my unreal is here is
working okay we should hop to
you um no finish your thought finish
your thought are you you or are you just
you just messing around at this point
I'm just messing around okay all right
I'm going to see if I can't get a
character going
um let's do a little flippy flip uh one
second I got like 80
screens
there we go got our oh yeah we got our
snow going freaking cool so easy amazing
all right
ums so we have a giant castle this is
very fitting
actually let's see there we go this is
very fitting for this scene holy
crap
oh nice yeah there you go
perfect I love how it comes in at the
right scale
definitely get it in like the fog back
here like peing out like
this oh the reveal oh yeah the BB clouds
are
awesome yeah love it oh Justin
with the Super Chat we might have a card
draw soon s mon I don't know if the card
draw is on or not but Justin says since
since potty language is allowed do you
guys care to comment on
how poo poo time is also PP time but PP
time is almost never poooo time that's a
great um that is
gendered I I had this I've said this
realization too and my wife was like not
for you man
oh man I'm still trying to make sense of
this comment that's what I'm trying to
do it's well it's that you're if you're
peee time if you're poooo time you're
sitting down and you're probably peeing
I think but if you're peeing if you're a
dude you're not sitting down so why are
you pooping dude sometimes I will sit
cuz I'm just trying to chill well if
you're well then maybe then maybe uh
trying to play the switch a little bit
you know it's like but yes I I it is
often um not yes but and then my wife
was like
like wow how we got thank you
Justin SOA let me know know if there's a
card draw I'm trying to keep my my eyes
peeled on both of these
sides oh I see I see
yeah all right so we're in the
scene um we're going to try and get a
character on here let's get the little
pirate guy going let's get him let's get
him I am flying through this all right
let's bring this down
okay so the way to do this um so you
might want to move me up to the top left
please and then we'll wrap this up
pretty soon here so pirate all right I
got the it comes in both I'll probably
use the u5 cuz I think u5 comes with
control rig uh full or SE
should good now I can switch these out
want when once I get it set up right yep
yep fully hot swappable should be let's
grab this
version so here's another weird thing
this is so weird you see how the
snapping what is this uh surface
snapping should work right like he
should land on the steps but he's
not apparently the fix for that is so
dumb I think it's a bug if you
open the a new level you make a new
level and then come back into into this
level it'll work so that's weird there's
so many things like that in unreal still
all right I drag this in I find oh fail
nope um okay so the first thing we need
to do is you're going to go open up his
meshesh and although it is compatible
control e you could do okay yep yep yep
yep
yep and we need to tell unreal hey it
you are compatible with that skeleton so
you go to the skeleton tab top
right get skeleton yeah
yep
yep oh maybe it already knows it but
still I think you go up to window
window asset
details yeah here see compatible
skeletons and in this case it's the four
the five skeleton it's the five all
right got it yes and save
boom saved now it's done now you yeah
now you drag yeah well now I won't I'll
shut up no no no no this good it's good
so I'm going to drag it in no you you do
it see that's so annoying you have to
drag it on top you have to drag it on
which makes no sense oh what the heck
all right all right and we're going to
add a
animation y but there is yeah so you you
yep that's fine but you did there was
already an animation track there so I
like to add it to the one that's that's
already there it doesn't matter no no no
this you can delete yeah this is good
that's what I like to do thank you
keeping me on my toes mhm then we
align
yep so annoying that it's never the
pivot point which is so impossible to
change I know I set up some hot Keys cuz
it's like the worst the The Anchor Point
business yeah it's
annoying looks good
yeah looks
great yes dude there you go and then how
do you do the simulate contrl s uh alt
s you might not have
cloth
abort uh to so that's interesting yeah
because when you do movie render
que that
will happen it's all good it's all good
I'll figure that it's because of the
yeah it's cuz I have hidden versus
invisible um yeah oh right right so I do
need to turn these guys I could probably
just get these guys out but I'm just
going to turn it's nice to keep them in
yeah because you you'll probably end up
using them
again and then all right so we got the
pirate guy
in yeah
and if I wanted to do any like
tweaking then it so I don't know this is
this is something that I'm always a
little unsure of in theory you should be
able to
rightclick on your pirate guy sequencer
go up to bake to control rig yeah it
this should work I don't will it work
we'll
see good this is the yeah yeah hit
it mannequin B oh this yours was doing
this weird thing where it didn't show
you the null on screen yeah why was that
happening there it is g gy
g there you go it does work that's so
awesome so the body I just do an
additive exactly and and um o um I
brought it down I would drag it yeah
yeah um and so the big difference here
why this is so cool is because
for ui5 compatible skeletons you have
this control rig which snaps to your
character so this is your character has
different proportions than the mannequin
does for ui4 there was never this they
didn't have this yeah but look at that
so cool awesome um per beautiful yeah
and I think you have to turn on ik
there's a there's an FK ik switch so
let's say you want to do the yes so this
is FK currently yes
yes um if you want to do ik there's a
switch uh field that you have to go find
and you have to trigger that uh it's
like at the top I think Global ik FK I
think it's at the top of the things
anyway it's fine in this case because
you just want to sorry I was I was
actually stuck here because like it's
not adding the key frame for some
reason like when I
uh when you click oh wait what this guy
oh that's that that's why I'm on the
wrong you might have been on yeah yeah
you were on the wrong is there auto key
frame in uh there is it's the uh left
two this one Auto
okay yeah remember that it's on
yep copy
paste out and in yeah that's great so
the FK ik
switcher that's at the top I believe top
what you say what do you
mean no no it's in the it's in the thing
it's in like this
list go down um maybe it's not at the
top okay never mind it should be if you
type in switch into tracks because you
can search through the sequencer in that
search bar type in
switch yeah see this you need to see how
see how it's keyed you can actually key
between I and FK which is really cool so
you you would have to you have to go and
delete these whole tracks if you want to
switch which these aren't really doing
anything so maybe for the feet you could
try doing it for the feet like yeah
let's see uh leg FK i k yeah so if I
delete the these key frames I forget
which one is
on oh maybe it's actually already on
though maybe you don't want to delete it
grab the grab the foot the controller
the blue one move that around oh yeah oh
never mind that's already that's cool
already set to so you don't need to for
the arms you would have to delete all
those key frames mhm click on and then
it would be I see I see
um let's see all right yans with the
Super Chat how do you resolve clothes
clipping in uee is that even a thing
like you just have to pull it out a
little bit or what oh man so I I maybe
this is a question about the cloth
system itself so one thing so I don't I
I don't know I mean if you have a hand
you resolve clipping if there are no
bones for the cloth if the hand is going
through the cloth I think the easiest
way to do it is is use one of these
systems to edit the hand so it doesn't
do that right yeah if it's if it has to
do it
um and and it's uh I don't know if
there's a way to like resolve it at the
cloth level now one thing that will
often happen is that again when you use
movie render queue it jumps into to
simulate mode and that means the first
five or six frames the cloth often goes
crazy um because it's jumping on now
what you can do in the movie render
queue is you can set the engine warmup
time uh so you usually you add
antialiasing load right yeah use your
your
settings click on the anti-aliasing and
advanced
nope if you tick that Ender engine uh
warmup time to like 100 100 frames it
will render it will it will warm the
engine up it will it will give you 100
frames of the engine working so the
cloth will settle if you're using Ultra
dnamic weather often times the when you
start simulating the snow hasn't fallen
yet so you want to kick this up to 500
frames so it has 500 frames of the snow
falling before you're render start so
that is how and it's engine it's engine
warm up not Rend this check box would be
to to render those frames that's if you
want to if you want to render those
which I don't know why you would but I
always yeah you want to have the engine
warm up so that's that's one thing and
then also I know and I don't know how to
do this but they added a cloth caching
system in unreal 5 now so you
can because it's nice to know what your
will look like you can cash out your
cloth Sim in the sequencer so search for
cloth cashing in the unreal
documentation or in Google you'll find a
method and tutorials to to do that but
you can do that now I forget how you do
it good question y I hope that answers
the question yeah no that's helpful um
cuz I wouldn't know super pertinent yeah
um and also shout out for that fifth
Super Chat man that's sick thank you
thanks for the
support
um let's see the ik switch should be in
global
control Global control yeah probably oh
yeah that makes sense yeah Bo yeah good
call thank you thank Youk you um I mean
dude other than that like I think I
think we're good we we've been streaming
for a while um I know man I know we did
a real nice overview we learned how to
add characters and all the major
programs um freaking thank you so much
Sam
I really really appreciate you being
here hanging out with us
and giving out that info so much fun um
so yeah for those of you guys um who are
watching the stream now you missed the
earlier stuff this video will be on you
know forever so you can go back I'm
going to go through time code it make
sure you guys got the blender the May
and the c4d parts um if you didn't hear
kit bash 3D is now a sponsor of uh this
challenge they're giv out prizes right
so top five get cargo for cargo Pro for
three months top 100 get a kit of their
choice between five kits so thank you
Kip bash much appreciated um dude I
other than that uh I think we're good
Sam do you want to touch on anything
else before we call
it I'll be trying to join your live
streams in the chat to help out I will
be doing mine Thursdays 11:00 p.m. PS
11: a.m. PST uh on the roko channel if
you have questions about your map you
know I will do my best to help you out
we can talk about specific
problems and um yeah again I just want
to call out we've spent I've spent so
much time in effort uh trying to put out
good tutorials on the Roco channel for
map if you have questions that's a great
place to start that ultimate
retargeting uh workflow playlist
probably will answer a lot of your
questions and if you're an unreal we
have links to the resources with that
control rig which is now in this video
and everything and and so yeah hopefully
I hope this was thank you for having me
man thank you SoDo for being so awesome
as always and um it's it's it's I I'm so
it's really uh I really appreciate it
because map is scary and intimidating so
many people have not worked with it
before and I do hope this helped demissy
I know you did because I had questions
and you answered them and uh I really
appreciate it thank you Sam thank you
for being here man and uh yeah guys
check out Sam's live stream on roko
right roko YouTube channel Thursday at
11: a.m. this whole month
right the do Jaber walk on instram
jabber walk on Instagram go follow Sam
check him out yeah thank you Sam you're
the
best thank you much appreciate thanks
for having I'll see you guys later
[Music]
peace